Anthony blinken has come to Jerusalem to
try and calm the violence which
threatens to spiral out of control
this trip was already planned before the
recent Terror attacks but there is now
an urgency to his talks with the
Israelis and Palestinians over the next
24 hours we're urging uh all sides now
to take
urgent steps to restore calm to
de-escalate we want to make sure that
there's an environment in which we can I
hope at some point create the conditions
where we can start to restore a sense of
security
Palestinians say their anger comes from
years of unequal treatment by people who
are occupying their land
it's night time and we're high in the
West Bank Hills South of Jerusalem every
evening men from the Palestinian Village
of batia down in the valley take it in
turns to come up and keep watch to stop
an Israeli settler building here
what is his claim to the land what does
he say his right to this land is he
starts saying this is the promised land
of Israel and this is the land of the
state of Israel and I have the right to
be here but he never showed any evidence
of land ownership Hassan is worried
because the Israeli government is
hardening its policies towards
Palestinians
I want to live in this I want to live in
Freedom
Israeli officials who govern the city
argue that Palestinians can only blame
themselves for the situation they're in
they wanted statehood and the autonomy
that they received during Oslo was the
preparation for Statehood what have they
done with that autonomy
enrich themselves create any opportunity
for their people create jobs build
hospitals they've done none of that
they've just allowed all this hatred to
Fester into terrorism seven Israelis and
16 Palestinians including one today have
been killed in the past week alone
peace talks seem a long way off and the
prospect of a two-state solution is an
absolute non-starter
Aleister bunkel Sky News in Jerusalem